قررت الى الماسك قد تقص اجنحه العصفور
المغرد تويتر فارادات تويتر بدات تتاثر
بقرارات الملك الجديد والدليل هو هروبه
بعض المعلمين عدد من الشركه الكبرى اعلى
ثقافه اعلاناتها مؤقتا على تويتر من بينها
جي ام اودي فايزر وجونيرال ميلز وفولز فاك
هذه الشركات تتخوف من التغيرات المحتمله
في سياسات تويتر حيث قالت شركه فولسفاجن
مثلا انها تراقب الوضع عن كثب وستقرروا
مسار الخطوه المواليه بناء على التطورات
وهنقلت شبكه
عميلا بتعليق الانفاق الاعلانيه على تويتر
من المغادره المفاجاه اما بسبب الاستقاله
او الاقاله لكبار المسؤولين التنفيذيين في
اقسام التسويق والمبيعات الاعلانيه على
تويتر الاكثر من ذلك هو ان شركات الاعلان
نفسها بدات تتخذ موقفا سلبيا من التعامل
مع تويتر حيث ذكرت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
هذا الاسبوع
احدى اكبر شركه الاعلام في العالم اصدرت
توصيه للعملاء بايقاف الانفاقهم مؤقتا على
تويتر